Here we see the solution to the quiz.
We have defined three new variables, g0, g1 and g2 for California.
Here we are going to plot the variables.
Let's first run this code.
Now that the variables are defined, we are going to
first make a plot of g0 and g2 with normed equals 0.
You should see a histogram that looks something like this.
Now we are going to make the histogram of g0 and g1.
Notice we have now changed normed equals 1.
We expect a normalized histogram.
Upon running the code, you should see two histograms.
One in red and one in green.
Notice the values in the y axis have changed.
In these histograms, the area under the curve here or
the count in each bin summed up must result to one.